[Musik]
unterstützung für kleine firmen und
freiberufler soforthilfen können ab
morgen beantragt werden bonuszahlungen
an mitarbeiter werden steuerfrei corona
krise in südeuropa immer mehr todesopfer
in italien und spanien
auch die regierung in madrid macht jetzt
einen großteil der unternehmen dicht und
brennpunkt new york der bürgermeister
schlägt alarm
us-präsident trump will die stadt aber
nicht unter quarantäne stellen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers sonntagabend herzlich
willkommen es ist schön dass sie bei uns
sind für diesen kompakten
nachrichtenüberblick natürlich mit dem
aktuellen stand im kampf gegen das virus
und sie beginnen bei uns schnell werden
die einschränkungen des lebens in
deutschland nicht vorbei sein das ist
klar
in der politik läuft jetzt aber eine
debatte über perspektiven und strategien
für die zeit danach und aus der
opposition heißt es der jetzige zustand
dafür keinen tag länger dauern als
medizinisch geboten
bund und länder teilen heute mit dass
die umsetzung der soforthilfen für
kleine unternehmen freiberufler
landwirte steht die anträge könnten in
den kommenden tagen gestellt werden
cornelia schiemenz die restaurantbetrieb
ist längst eingestellt dass machiavelli
in berlin mitte hat auf lieferservice
umgestellt und hofft so irgendwie bis zu
drei monate zu überbrücken
ich denke mal ein vierteljahr werde
möglich werden verlange ich bisher
keinen einzigen kündigung ausgesprochen
deutschland stehen mindestens noch drei
wochen kontakt beschränkungen bevor die
wirtschaft ächzt sofort hilfen des
bundes für selbstständige kleine
unternehmen und freiberufler stehen ab
morgen können sie beantragt werden wir
haben ein antragsformular erstellt das
den ländern als anhaltspunkt als muster
dient und wir gehen davon aus dass es so
kurz und so schnell wie möglich
geschehen soll deshalb weniger angaben
deshalb schnelles verfahren und wir
hoffen dass die bearbeitung in gang
kommt 50 milliarden euro stehen als
soforthilfe bereit
und auch sie sollen profitieren
supermarktmitarbeiter lagerarbeiter
pflegekräfte
diejenigen die jetzt extra schichten
fahren können ein steuerfreies lohnplus
erhalten
1500 euro können steuerfrei gezahlt
werden und ich hoffe übrigens auch dass
das eine motivation für die arbeitgeber
die noch etwas zögerlich sind ist das
gleichermaßen zu tun denn das ist
wirklich ein beitrag für sehr sehr hart
arbeiten
wann die wirtschaft wieder hochgefahren
wird will derzeit niemand sagen alles
hänge davon ab wie sich die
infektionszahlen entwickeln ja und dann
schauen wir auf die medizinische seite
und dort nimmt die sorge zu ob das
deutsche gesundheitssystem die
versorgung schwerkranker patienten
schafft thomas konsum hat den überblick
und beginnt mit denen die auch unter
normalen umständen besondere pflege
brauchen wolfsburg das hans willi heim
eigentlich ein schutzraum für schwache
und kranke durch das virus überwindet
alle barrieren seit gestern starben drei
weitere bewohner 15 tote sind es
insgesamt ein opfer von corona auch hier
und viele infektionen das heim in
wildeshausen bei oldenburg isoliert zb
die alten eltern sehen unmöglich es
besorgniserregend natürlich klar
und ich habe auch kein richter in
kontakt zur ebene die toten die kranken
all das wäre wohl vermeidbar gewesen
sagen patientenschützer seid jetzt zwei
monaten fordern wir schutzpläne für die
pflegeeinrichtungen in deutschland
wir haben aber bis vor kurzem gar nicht
getestet ob es entsprechende infektion
überhaupt in heimen gibt viel mehr
testen und vielmehr schutzkleidung sowie
forderungen atemmasken und kobe stellt
nun die bundesregierung ihre bedingungen
nicht verhandelbar
interessierte firmen sollen schnell
liefern schnell steigen auch die
fallzahlen stand 18 uhr 30 gibt es laut
johns hopkins universität 58 1247
bestätigte infektionen 455 menschen
starben
hinter den zahlen verbergen sich auch
schicksale von asylbewerbern acht
ansteckungen im anker zentrum
geldersheim bayern das heißt quarantäne
für 600 nicht mehr raus millionen halten
sich freiwillig daran auch wegen des
wetters es ist kalt geworden deutschland
ist daheim und wartet jetzt müssen wir
darauf gucken wie sich das virus
weltweit ausbreiten für den gesamten
globus gilt die korona pandemie fordert
immer mehr opfer
insgesamt meldet die johns hopkins
universität heute vor einer halben
stunde fast 686.000 bestätigte
infektionen und mehr als 32.000 tote wir
gehen die einzelnen länder jetzt mal
durch die es besonders schlimm trifft
und da ist zunächst italien das land hat
mit großem abstand die meisten
todesopfer zu beklagen mehr als 10.000
menschen sind dort bereits an den folgen
des virus gestorben
aus rom andreas postel dass die
supermärkte offen und die regale voll
sind ist das eine aber was nützt es dem
der kein geld verdient und das nötigste
zu kaufen in palermo ist die polizei in
alarmbereitschaft
sie müssen den leuten helfen die nicht
wissen was sie jetzt tun sollen die ihre
geschäfte geschlossen haben die ihre
beschäftigung nicht nachgehen können das
ist schrecklich italien geht in die
vierte woche des shutdown zum
monatsanfang werden für die menschen
mieten und kreditraten fällig die
caritas und caserta bei neapel spürt
einerseits eine größer werdende unruhe
und andererseits eine große
hilfsbereitschaft die italiener
es ist ein wunder der ausserordentlichen
solidarität sowohl von einzelspendern
als auch unternehmen die uns dinge
stiften die wir dann an die bedürftigen
verteilen können und besonders im
ärmeren süden soziale spannungen zu
vermeiden hat die italienische regierung
ein 4,3 milliarden euro schweres
hilfsprogramm aufgelegt für
einkaufsgutscheine und
lebensmittelpakete wir wollen niemanden
alleine lassen besonders in einer zeit
und in die gesamte nation so sehr leidet
müssen wir uns insbesondere um die
kümmern die besonders leiden
italien wartet darauf endlich aus dem
würgegriff des corona virus befreit zu
werden doch die regierung hier in rom
hat die italiener darauf eingestimmt
dass die sanktionen sicherlich noch eine
weile andauern werden und ausgangs
beschränkungen die bis zum dritten april
erlassen worden sind sollen nun bis nach
ostern zum 18 april verlängert werden so
die ankündigung der regierung in italien
auch in spanien sind es sehr schwierige
tage dort gelten jetzt noch strengere
ausgangsverbot als bisher
alle arbeiter und angestellten deren
tätigkeit nicht zwingend nötig ist
müssen in den zwangsurlaub die kliniken
haben große probleme mit der versorgung
von schwerkranken besonders in der
hauptstadt madrid christel haas überall
auf den fluren betten mit corona
patienten die krankenhäuser von madrid
sind hoffnungslos überfüllt ärzte und
pfleger am ende ihrer kräfte
seelisch ist es schrecklich wir
versuchen unser bestes aber ich weiß es
wird furchtbar diese angst die patienten
das macht dich fertig die älteren bitten
uns unter tränen nehmen sie mich bitte
auf aber wie entscheiden wen wir nehmen
das ist wie im krieg du ja du nein
es fehlen nicht nur betten sondern auch
beatmungsgeräte zumindest bei den masken
gibt es jetzt nachschub 1,2 millionen
stück kommen aus china an
die regierung hat die maßnahmen noch
einmal verschärft ab morgen dürfen nur
noch die zur arbeit die für die
grundversorgung des landes zuständig
sind
schon wieder dies sind sehr traurige und
bittere zeiten es sind entscheidende
tage in denen wir alle unsere kraft
brauchen werden
das virus bekämpfen mit allen mitteln
desinfektions drohnen fliegen durch
manche straßen das militär reinigt
regelmäßig öffentliche orte bahnhöfe zum
beispiel
der schultergurt hier bauen wir eine
station auf in der die leute
desinfiziert werden wenn sie aus dem
bahnhof kommen doch es gibt auch momente
der freude diese junge frau ist von
corinna geheilt das personal des
krankenhauses spendet die applaus und
auch ein wenig sich selbst und dann die
usa wo mittlerweile alle 50
bundesstaaten betroffen sind in keinem
anderen land der welt ist die zahl der
offiziell als infiziert gemeldeten so
hoch die experten schauen mit großer
sorge auf new orleans louisiana wo die
medizinischen geräte knapp werden und
die behörden um hilfe bitten
genau so ist die lage in new york city
die stadt fühle sich an wie in
kriegszeiten sagt ihr bürgermeister und
da gehen wir jetzt live in nach new york
zu johannes hano eines guten abend wie
hat man sich denn das leben vorzustellen
in dieser stadt die man sich ruhig kaum
vorstellen kann ja also der die gestern
hatte der präsident mit seiner aussage
er könnte sich vorstellen möglicherweise
eine quarantäne für new york anzuordnen
hierfür großen shop gesorgt der
gouverneur von new york hat sofort
scharf widersprochen hat gesagt das
würde eine katastrophe auslösen
hier in new york das sei weder rechtlich
noch praktisch überhaupt zu machen
die lebensmittelversorgung sei dann
nicht mehr garantiert die post würde
nicht mehr kommen die menschen würden in
eine panik geraten können da hat er
ebenfalls große angst davor gehabt dass
die menschen in panik geraten und
fluchtartig hier die gegend verlassen
jetzt hat man sich darauf geeinigt der
präsident hat noch mal drüber geschlafen
heute morgen hat gesagt okay keine
quarantäne
aber ein einreise und ausreise stopp
sozusagen eine art reisewarnung für new
york new jersey und connecticut die
nächsten zwei wochen soll hier niemand
mehr rein und niemand mehr raus aus der
stadt aus diesen bundesstaaten
das ganze wird sehr schwierig new york
ist schon jetzt unter locker und also
nicht lockt das ist falsch aber unter
einer art ausgangssperre die leute
halten sich einigermaßen dran denn die
situation ist wirklich dramatisch die
todeszahlen steigen rasant an
es gibt aber auch einen lichtblick der
gouverneur hat heute gerade gesagt die
zahl derer die ins krankenhaus müssen
verdoppelt sich langsamer als bisher
waren es am anfang alle zwei tage sind
es jetzt nur noch alle sechs tage also
da gibt es ein leichtes licht am
horizont sagt johannes hano live in
johannes herzlichen dank der präsident
von brasilien ja ihre ball szenario der
redet die pandemie nach wie vor und
ungerührt klein so geht das nicht hat
jetzt ein gericht in rio de janeiro
entschieden und damit eine kampagne
verboten die sich gegen die
ausgangssperren wendet die in einigen
regionen schon gelten
in einem video beispielsweise hatte die
regierung die menschen aufgefordert
trotz corona ihrem alltag nachzugehen
motto brasilien dürfe nicht stillstehen
die richter wiesen die regierung
szenario jetzt an künftig keine aufrufe
mehr zu starten die den
gesundheitsbehörden widersprechen
mit unserer zdf heute erhalten wir sie
jederzeit natürlich auf dem laufenden
aktuelle informationen gibt es in einem
live blog und außerdem finden sie einen
überblick über die situation in den
einzelnen ländern europas heute sonntag
in einer zeit in der die kirchen zu
bleiben müssen
beim gottesdienst hier in aachen den
baden württemberg waren heute trotzdem
etwa 600 menschen dabei alles mitglieder
der kirchengemeinde die dem pfarrer auf
dessen wunsch in ihr foto geschickt
hatten
der schaute dann bei seiner predigt in
vertraute gesichter und die kirche war
voller als sonst und die menschen hinter
den fotos haben die messe übrigens mit
gefeiert per videoübertragung im
internet zu hause bleiben müsste heute
deutlich leichter gefallen sein
draußen ist es nämlich ziemlich
ungemütlich und stürmisch geworden hier
an der ostseeküste zum beispiel fegten
böen mit windstärke neun bis zehn übers
wasser
das ging dann wenn überhaupt nur mit
viel talent und morgen im norden
einzelne schnee und regen schauer an den
alpen hört der schneefall langsam auf
dazwischen ist es sonnig bei null bis
neun grad und in den nächsten tagen wird
sonnige aber nur langsam wärmer eine
weitere woche in beispiellosen zeiten
geht zu ende
wir danken allen für das sehr große
interesse empfehlen den kollegen claus
kleber um 21.50 im heute-journal er hat
fragen an den bundesgesundheitsminister
und wir sind auch morgen wieder für sie
da punkt 7 versprochen
wo immer es geht machen sie sich einen
angenehmen abend